this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by our
supporters on patreon in the case of the
particular podcast that you are about to
watch video game writing 101 which comes
out on the second monday of every month
patreon got it two days early and
completely unedited i did have to make a
lot of edits to this one just to make
sure it was completely safe for youtube
because we ended up talking about some
things but not safe for work and i don't
want to hurt the views of this already
very niche podcast topic so if you would
like to help out help pay contributors
and support the content as it is check
out the link in the description or go to
patreon.com charolanazard hello everyone
i'm alana welcome to videogamewriting101
this is cliffy b cliff blazinski uh
cliff for anyone who doesn't know you
who are you exactly
um i made video games for 25 years i
worked at epic for 20 years i started my
own studio called bosque productions we
made two games that unfortunately didn't
get much traction um and now i'm working
actually it's pretty much done i have a
memoir coming out november 1st called
call control freak
[Music]
yeah
well the thing is is um and also so i'm
also somehow stumbled into being a
broadway producer so that's my tattoo
i'm working on other secret projects i
can't really talk about too so it's lots
of stuff really yeah the broadway thing
is fascinating though not necessarily as
related to this podcast but i have so
many questions about that like how that
started
what that means
are you just throwing money at broadway
productions
um i mean it's it's basically it is an
investment right
the thing is um so
are you familiar with the show dear evan
hansen
i'm not no
uh i'm not gonna pitch this show but uh
there's a character in there um
basically the actor was a fan of my
video game work and he slid him into my
dms
and he basically was like hey you know
we're looking for fresh producing blood
you know as opposed to like you know
70 year old women who live in the
hamptons and [ __ ] right and so i was
like yeah because you know broadway
means the world to me because um when i
was 15 and this is also in the book my
father died my mother was listening to
phantom of the opera on repeat and
phantom you know it's one of the og kind
of musicals for me at least and it
really resonated with me and so uh
very unique way to get into that
well yeah and then so then um you know
we i co-produced a hades town which
wound up winning eight tony's and then
when my studio boss key productions
crumbled um they broke my heart it
really [ __ ] me up for a good year the
internet was like the total shot and
fraud like huh cocky game 2900 studio
fail i'm gonna do a youtube video about
it kind of [ __ ] yeah and i'm just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] this [ __ ] people still give
you [ __ ] over it which is like
the idea that you would want it to
to go that way seems nuts to me but
that's a lot of the projection it seems
wild and then like it's a new [ __ ]
material you know like
insult like my dog or something no
i'll never insult your dogs they're too
cute
and then to uh to to be
be at radio city music hall uh you know
the missus and i all dressed up and to
see it when eight tony's like
like
like it was the the much-needed win that
i needed and uh it's it's you know
there's another musical that we're going
to co-produce uh upcoming that i can't
talk about but it's going to be [ __ ]
huge um
maybe have mentioned to me slightly
slightly i'm just going to say people
should be very excited
this person is uh it's based around is
in the zeitgeist so i'll leave it at
that yeah um but yeah so yeah so how did
you stumble into the whole writing gig
by the way isn't it about me and i've
been writing my whole life like i think
i just mentioned before we started
recording i was writing books when i was
like 12. so the two things that i cared
about my whole life were writing and
video games and i paired those
originally through journalism and you
know i started out in print magazines um
went and got the
four years studying journalism at
university but the other half of my
major was entertainment writing so when
i realized that i had kind of done all
the journalism there was to do
i started trying to i'd always written
fiction but write more fiction for
sample purposes and then i did game jams
and then i started writing for a couple
of indie games and was doing all the
stuff under a different name
um and then i i effectively got lucky i
expected expected to have to start out
at an indie studio uh but they had a
junior writer position at santa monica
studios so i went for it it's like i
feel like i am qualified to be a junior
writer see the back of my book back my
um oh my gosh very nice
it's quite a branding you have there
my favorite thing these days is to just
go go to a pub with the misses and just
read a book
you know and like no way memoirs the
whole nine yards oh yeah i i love
reading books about demographics that
aren't necessarily me uh to kind of gain
empathy for you know people that aren't
me you know like i read um yeah you know
the new jim crow um there's a book
called uh contested waters that kind of
explains why you know uh public pools uh
in like post-segregation america were
very controversial for african-americans
like swimming and whatnot that's why a
lot of black people don't swim to this
day right wow um and so much of this
stuff is so entrenched in america it's
[ __ ] unbelievable there's there's uh
definitely something about just picking
up a book about something that you know
nothing about i read a lot of books
about ai i guess probably to the extent
that now i know things about ai but you
should just like go to a bookstore and
that would be the thing i would seek out
i would just buy a new ai book and
lately i've been reading warhammer with
the law in warhammer is so [ __ ] good
no [ __ ] before we rant about books i did
want to ask
do you feel like there's an overlap
between the design of a musical and game
design absolutely um it's a miracle that
a video game ever ships as you're
learning or as you know um and the fact
that you look at like a musical
and the fact that the you know you're
looking at lighting choreography music
uh a live band essentially you know you
know somebody could get sick you know
then you wind up you know you having to
have an understudy that has to nail all
their beats they have to hit their marks
on stage like there's so much overlap
there and so much could go wrong on any
given night and the thing is is um they
have to do this eight times a week for
two and a half hours right
and i have tremendous amount of respect
for the performers and uh yeah it's just
uh you know we're actually heading up to
new york in about a week and a half i'm
gonna go see a couple of more shows as
well and um just you know my
niece is 17 and she's a huge broadway
nerd and uh yeah um the last time i uh
was in california i went to her
quinceanera and uh she just you know
she's just a wonderful wonderful kid and
she you know
right when she was going through her
phase of being bullied by the girls at
her school i was being bullied by the
internet as my studio and so it's the
whole thing like with the rescue dog
it's like did i save her did she save me
you know
so i basically like paid for her right
now to be in new york to be doing this
kind of a two-week boot camp for uh for
a
theater and we just we bond over
broadway like like hard like you know
like oh my god like did you see this
this this performance you see did you
see that you see the other and and you
know we went to
manhattan a couple months ago as kovan
was
seemingly easing um and we got to see
some of the shows that you know i i
wanted to see for a while like uh six
which is [ __ ] incredible i had very
good things about it
it's like as the kids say it slaps
imagine
[Laughter]
it's it's it's the story of uh henry
viii's six wives
and but told kind of by way of what
feels like a 90-minute spice girls
concert oh yeah i'm down
that's great no it's incredibly catchy
but broadway is near and dear to me um
like i'm a big karaoke nerd i don't know
if you've seen on my twitter like you
know i i i call in the raleigh beer
garden and every monday night at eight
o'clock we uh we host karaoke and
i feel like you pre-plan your set lists
which is like professional karaoke i
literally have it on my phone and like
i'm not even that good you know i'm just
like i just go for i'm like we're not
gonna take it
it's about having a good time it really
is and um you know we get a really
eclectic mix of people there it's just
it's it's something that i love and you
know like the thing is
you know music is near and dear to me um
but i never really was formally trained
because i was the theater nerd in high
school um you know as a mercutio and
romeo and juliet uh you know lenny and
uh
neil simon's rumors you know i was the
lead in ten little indians and all that
and um it's uh it's something that just
you know will always
be
close to my heart i think my next tattoo
is gonna be the comedy and tragedy
symbol oh nice did you ever think about
making a musical video game
i did the thing is is you know
i
in regards to video games
like
in the words of danny glover and lethal
weapon i feel like i'm too old for this
[ __ ]
like and i i tell i i consult with game
developers a lot like my i'm still
friends with a lot of people at bosque
um that have moved on
since obviously and i tell them do what
you can to get [ __ ] you money or just
enough to be comfortable and if you
can't get the [ __ ] out it's probably
very hard i don't think a lot of people
in games making [ __ ] you money
no i mean i lucked out you know tim
sweeney and mark rain were very very
good to me and then i was fortunate
enough to invest in oculus um
i use my quest still almost every day i
love it
dude like it's it's one of those things
like i i looked at the very very first
version of it like like the duct taped
version and i was like i'm like i want
in
yeah it was awesome the first time i
tried it and it's only gotten better um
speaking of uh
theater have you seen sleep no more
oh yeah we've done it three times
nice i i've only done it once and i'd
love to do it multiple times but did you
get
so for the for those who aren't familiar
with it like listening or watching could
you like pitch it
sleep no more is you show up at this
sort of warehouse type thing uh
in chelsea in chelsea in in manhattan
and um
it's
macbeth played out in different rooms
sort of simultaneously and it's several
flaws and you have the option to
pursue one actor and follow them through
this building as their play plays out
it's like a stampede scenes yeah it's
it's fascinating and also i think very
game designy um in a way that
i would actually love for games to
emulate that even a little bit better
wait you you straight up the full player
agency you straight up opt into which
stories that you want to see and which
ones that you don't want to see and i
think that like you could probably have
a weird experience if you just jump
between stuff all the time and nothing
would make sense i chose to follow
somebody and then
that thing stopped and i followed
somebody else and watch scenes in
certain rooms play out and sometimes
you'll hear people be like there's
something really interesting this way
and then you just walk in a different
direction well did you do so the thing
is is also
for those watching like you you have to
wear a mask yeah it's it like it's like
some eyes wide shut [ __ ] and you're not
you're not allowed to talk right and
they have like bouncers there and
everything like that but basically like
sometimes if you like appear really
engaged with the performance of what's
going on they will sometimes pull you
into like a back area and then like have
like a one-on-one interaction with you
and it never happened to me it happened
to my sister-in-law because she's you
know super hilarious and charismatic and
uh but i'll never forget like the first
time we went like we saw this um this
lady going through what looked like a
world war ii
hospital jumps through a window we jump
through the window and follow her
through like this this like makeshift
forest and then she winds up in like
this little cabin with this other woman
and they're having this interaction and
and then also the um
you know the whole thing about lady
macbeth and out damn spot you know the
whole like getting the blood out of her
hands uh i don't know if they do this
these days um but back when we went the
actress there there's a clawfoot uh
bathtub and the lady who plays you know
lady macbeth goes over to the tub strips
down in front of everybody that was that
when i did it
yeah buddha's naked right yeah
and gets in the tub and she she had a
little blood capsule obviously but she's
like you know washing the blood out of
her hands and everything like that and
it's just like it's one of the most
surreal
amazing experiences like i've ever had
like
it's extremely uncomfortable in a
strange way too like i felt very very
vulnerable because especially because i
was there by myself and i think you're
encouraged to split up if you you go in
a group um so you feel uncomfortable and
vulnerable while also being extremely
engaged in things you've never seen
before it's well the other thing is it
it it starts off where you wind up in
this kind of like you know bioshock vibe
speakeasy where there's like there's
like this ella fitzgerald lady like
singing and some of the cast members are
there like you know feeling totally like
bioshock and like tuxes like drink
drinking mocktails and act staying in
character and it's just it's immersive
as hell and it's it's [ __ ] brilliant
yeah i think ken levine said that
bioshock was in part inspired by sleep
no more so
okay vibes are very much there um yeah i
could talk about that forever but to
pivot away uh to to writing so how's
how's working on a memoir what what does
that entail exactly i know you've been
doing it for a while like i can't even
imagine where do you start what do you
choose to include like
what is that process
uh as a fellow writer like there's
nothing more intimidating than opening
like microsoft word and seeing the blank
page right
and so you know start with it was a dark
and stormy night you know that kind of
stuff right but i mean that's the thing
about
memoirs is
i would not recommend writing one
because that's mistake don't do it i i
know i mean i i mean i'll make a little
bit of money off of it right but the
thing is is uh it was in some ways
therapy for me because in some ways it
was reliving like last like past trauma
because
there have been video game books written
many video game books written but none
of them have been very deeply personal
and this one for me like i basically
talk about you know uh like it
ultimately let me back up for a second
it ultimately wants to be a love story
where you know you have a pimply faced
you know unpopular nerd in high school
who grows up as the video game grows up
the video ministry grows up alongside
him and then ultimately you know gets
enough money to [ __ ] off but finds true
love in the process right
but the thing is is i put it all out
there because when i was 15 years old i
lost in the nintendo world championships
1990 uh my father died and i was
molested by a dude i met online all in
the same year
yes jesus so you wonder why i have a
case for arrested development
and the thing about the thing about the
the the the trauma and everything like
that it's like i think you know being a
somewhat public figure for myself if i
can put this out there and kind of like
share it those who don't feel
comfortable talking about it or sharing
it will find some sort of solace in it
you know definitely
and so uh it's um
it was a lot of [ __ ] work and the
like the the editing process
uh the league like i interacted with a
million developers in my entire career
and so my editor uh
sean manning
had simon schuster he's like there's too
many characters i'm like okay
and um so we had to edit that back
but i went up uh you know so basically
it was it was kind of a hybrid approach
where i i wrote like 80 of it but then i
was working with this uh the ghostwriter
todd gold
if you uh google him he um he did little
girl lost uh but
drew barrymore's book um he did uh the
osborne's books uh he's done a bazillion
books and like this guy you remember the
uh the movie almost famous yeah by
cameron crowe cameron crowe was a a rock
star journalist you know that's kind of
autobio autobiographical for him right
todd todd did the same thing he was
embedded with michael jackson in japan
in the 80s he's showing me photos of him
and bubbles the [ __ ] chimp wow what
the hell and then he he was embedded
with madonna in london in the 80s right
like and so like like todd when's your
memoir coming out
and he's got this this great way about
him he's like this like you know late
50s early 60s guy and he just you know
he's like you know we're talking about
billy joel at one point and i was
talking about christy brinkley he sent
me a photo of him and christy brinkley
which for those of you who are too young
to remember she was the ultimate 80s
dream girl
and uh and so basically uh he was almost
like a therapist you know so we do a
combination of like me sending pages to
him he edit them send it just in the
back ask me questions um he do you know
like verbal interviews with me and
things like that over the phone i would
love that job honestly there was a
period of time in in high school where i
found out what a ghostwriter was
and i wanted to do it and i still think
that's something that i'll probably end
up doing like one day down the line is
like i feel like hearing interviewing
people and hearing their stories and
then translating that to some sort of
narrative it sounds super fun but i
think that's uh i think the books that
ice t's written you know he's it was
kind of a hybrid approach for him you
know having like an interviewer like a
ghostwriter and i'm actually writing
writing some of the pages and things
like that um the funny fact is i imagine
lauren has also helped you with it a
fair amount
yeah i would think
she's probably had a pretty big impact
on like what you write and what you
don't write like that's gotta be
something you gotta confide in your
loved ones well it's kind of nice when
you you know we're actually um
we'll get back to the book in a second
um we're actually throwing uh a renew
and a renewal ceremony for our uh our
wedding vows so that's uh coming up ten
year anniversary of being married um so
we're gonna throw a soiree nice in in
downtown raleigh and uh you know we're
doing the whole thing again we're gonna
write our own vows and i'm gonna see my
my friends are gonna see me sob like a
[ __ ]
so can i come i'll be there uh you're
welcome to join yeah
that sounds awesome congratulations but
yeah so yeah the whole thing about the
you know writing and everything like
that it's like
you know it's it's a lot like game
design where
you know you you have your first version
and you think it's good and then it
bounces back to the publisher and you're
like
no this is [ __ ] trash
stop edit it like the first draft was
like 350 pages and then once they edited
it down it was 200 pages and then once
you know todd and i had a lot more
conversations we fluffed it back up to
being um like 308 pages and then you
know you have to do acknowledgements you
have to do you have to vet it legally
you have to vet it legally because
my former employer still you know
friendly with them like i go to like
hockey games with mark green still once
in a while right we text often and uh
it's one of those things they have more
money than god and the last thing
anybody wants is a lawsuit so yeah it's
not like you're going to crack the book
and be like here's the secret to what
makes the unreal engine successful
like no you know
the majority of what's in there uh is
public knowledge right but it's it's
perspective on public knowledge exactly
it's viewed for my from my you know my
lens of me you know trying to come up
and be a charismatic interesting person
in this summer this emerging market the
the thing is
about writing
there's a reason why there's writers for
treats right yeah like you know
isolation actually helps a lot and so
i'll tell you another quick story as i
rehydrate
all right
chapstick get it gonna be able to do it
one-handed
um the um so
a couple years ago my mother-in-law who
was a saint
uh was diagnosed with stage four lung
cancer i'm so sorry and never smoked a
day in her life you know raised four
wonderful kids uh was you know grew up
in alabama in a trailer one up you know
working her way to middle class um just
wonderful wonderful woman right
and so
um we had to go back and forth to the
suburbs of louisiana like non-stop and
at first it was like i didn't really
realize like it had metastasized i
didn't really realize what a death
sentence it was and so before cove had
truly hit i'm like sweet i get to go
back to new orleans and go to all the
restaurants and the bars and you know
listen to jazz and throw a parade and
[ __ ] and uh then copen really hit and we
wind up having to stay across the lake
in mandeville which is it's nice but by
nice it means it has like a pizza hut in
the subway because it's across the lake
and whatnot
oh boy let's go to chili's
and
we wound up having to stay in airbnbs of
uh debatable quality um but i had my
laptop there and um basically like
sitting there you know realizing how
life is short and seeing the slow
decline of her because
the thing about blazinski's is
blazinskis usually go like that
like my father you know had that heart
attack when i was 15. boom done double
goals
my age 47. damn
yeah um he he's he's i'm pretty sure
he's uh uh sneaking cigarettes towards
his at the end of his life 47
yeah yeah and and then um yeah genetic
starter [ __ ] and so that's why
you know try and make sure to watch my
uh pounds and
smoke whatever you like i'll never
forget i was at uh staying at the
the ritz marina del rey and i just
walked to the green dot and it was like
a it was like a [ __ ] apple store my
dad is planning to come visit soon and
my dad's always smoked weed but it's
still very illegal in australia and he
was like danny of your friends smoke can
i can i get some weeds any friends i was
like dad we don't need friends i can put
in a [ __ ] app you'll get weed to the
door in 15 minutes so i'm planning to
take him to i was gonna ask some of my
stoner friends
what the like coolest
dispensary is to take him in person
because i think it'll blow his mind in
australia they're still in the area
where you don't have strains of weed you
just have weed that you buy from some
guy on a corner illegally there's no
like this one does this and this is from
here like but then it's it's it's not
like regulated and like in this not safe
at all it's gonna be fentanyl in it or
some [ __ ] like
it never made sense to me like drug
dealers putting fentanyl in their stuff
like you're you're killing your client
telling you i actually don't know why
they do that
it's [ __ ] weird um but anyway yeah we
uh we went to some
avra levine in toronto a couple months
ago and also it's completely legal in
canada and so just like walking into the
store i'm just like
give me everything yeah um anyway
where's that going with this i lost my
channel so basically like just sitting
there like you know with the laptop and
these airbnbs you know and and watching
my mother-in-law slowly decline um it it
really makes you realize what's
important in life
you know and
talking about you know the time i spent
in canada developing the first unreal
talking about you know meeting bill
gates talking about uh you know going on
stage at grommen's chinese theater to
show off gears one and
realizing how that would change my life
so much and people still to this day are
like
come back and save gears i'm like
look [ __ ] i've said publicly i
will consult like and nobody's reached
out to me like i've i phil spencer in my
dm's you know like whatever like it is
what it is but if they want to fine
otherwise i'm happy to consult on other
projects but you know the thing is
writing um oh back to writing so i i
picked up um stephen king's book on
writing yes i read that
and i i told my writing partner todd
gold you know when i picked up the book
and he's like don't read that
and i'm like what it's basically for a
lot of writers it's like save the cat
for screenwriters yeah and
like you know you know you know tj
fixman right yes yeah tj's you know
writer wrote
insomniac you write screenplays these
days he's friends with david hasselhoff
anyway
it's
it's reference everybody save the cat is
a screenwriting book that is much more
about the business side of screenwriting
than it is about like how to actually
write a screenplay and it's kind of
controversial because it tells you to
write a generic screenplay to make money
i think there's value in that in the in
that like
there's stuff in it that it's like you
if you're going to write a screenplay
successfully and you want to be a
full-time job you do need some of the
advice in that book but it also like is
not actually helpful for beginning
writing the screenplay itself it's like
make a christmas movie to make money
well the thing is so you know i'm a huge
pop culture junkie right like i read
every issue of entertainment weekly for
20 years right like i've sat there at
the beach with my wife one time and like
she's going over like movies like you
know name the director i'm like david
fincher you know [ __ ] whatever and
like i i i know my my numbers and that's
why you know like for those of you
who don't know like usually
at comic-con um justin roiland from rick
and morty and alex hirsch from gravity
falls and i would throw what we'd call
the big dumb yacht party and we get them
there's no big dumb yup party this year
i know we but we get the most eclectic
mix of people alana came a couple times
um and then like you know like the cast
of game of thrones is there
like uh
weird al came one time uh lin-manuel
miranda from hamilton uh kelly ripa and
her husband like uh the cast of
riverdale like just you know all sorts
of interesting people very big mixes of
people too my favorite thing is like
seeing a cosplayer who's like still hoff
in cosplay makeup interact with like
some random actor like it's well that's
the whole thing
my mind well yeah exactly the whole idea
is you don't have to be like just a
famous person you have to be an
interesting person yeah you didn't do a
bougie celebrity party it's not like
stupid in that way it's it's just a lot
of very interesting people
apparently machine gun kelly was there
one year huh
yeah my boy my boy got a photo with him
and so i'm like okay but yeah but yeah
like uh that's the thing is you know i
just i love entertainment you know the
thing about save the cat
is one of the the points that really
resonated for me is he calls out if you
recall what was called the dark knight
of the soul
where it's like boy meets girl boy loses
girl and it's like you know there's he's
like always he's like walking
like it's dark it's raining out and it's
like he's lost everything and that's
like the transition to act three right
that's the thing is you know i picked up
you know uh final draft and uh you know
i i did a short and i'm hoping to film
it at some point um and i'm not gonna
pitch it right now but basically like
you know learning the little like ins
and outs of like final draft and how to
actually like work with that it's it's a
brilliant little program i highly
recommend to anybody who's watching this
podcast who wants to be a writer just
learn how to use final draft like you
will almost definitely need to at some
point in your career but the thing is
alana i have to ask you like why do you
want to write for video games because
there's a reason every the three gears
games that i really worked on had like
three different writers because it will
grind this [ __ ]
it will grind you down like it is it is
a rough rough racket still going through
that
um
i just love video games and i think i
don't think that i will want to do it
forever like it it already feels that
way
right now what i get out of getting to
write at a place like santa monica
studio which is like in my opinion an
absolutely world-class studio is access
to people who are the absolute best in
the world at what they do
and i just get to absorb all their
knowledge i feel like every day that i
go to work i'm at university and i'm
learning from these people who have so
much knowledge and experience and it's
just it's so rewarding i almost feel
like i should be paying the studio for
me to get to work there because i get to
just learn from all these people about
like different opinions on game design
and then one of my favorite things to do
is ask people internally how they feel
about a recent release that they played
because the perspective that you get
from game devs is so different from a
lot of the public perspective in a way
that is just fascinating you find out
what other people did wrong and it's
super interesting
there's this thing about game developers
right there's two types there's the
young bright-eyed and bushy-tailed ones
that love everything and then there's
the jaded ones that will tear everything
down like i played it
and it's
so vicious too i was like damn i didn't
even think that was a problem
yeah yeah but it's fascinating but i
mean for my my problem like you know
having worked in games as long as i have
is a good part of my job was playing
spot the difference
i'd go on like a you know a five day
five european city press tour to like
promote the video game and then i come
back and like the camera would be [ __ ]
up or the blood would be looking stupid
and i'd be like what the hell like
there's one time
when i was at bosque and one of my pr
program well one of the the things
programmers like to do because
programmers all have a god complex
remember the
famous alec baldwin monologue from
malice
look it up it's it's legendary it's like
you ask because he's a doctor and
there's a whole legal case with it and
everything like that and you know it's
like you ask me if i have a god complex
i am god oh you know what i've heard
that reference but i've not actually
seen the movie i've definitely seen that
reference being being a theater nerd i
just like late at night i just love
looking up like monologues like the
glengarry glen ross one where it's like
you know what it takes to sell real
estate brass balls right that's why you
loved midnight mass
exactly that whole scene um that whole
scene where um the main guy uh was his
name riley i think yeah um you know for
those of you who don't know he um you
know he's an alcoholic uh recovered uh
at this small town and but he's having
this conversation with this girl that
they kind of have a vibe right and
they're sitting on the sofa look it up
on youtube it's called what happens when
we die and he does this incredible
monologue talking about you know
dmt being released and you dream the
ultimate dream and then
nothing and i
my wife catches me watching the
monologue on a regular basis and it
triggers her it triggers her from her
watching her mother die
right and so for me that's therapy right
because you know like i said blessings
died fast my nephew at 20 died in a car
accident um you know my mother hit her
head and fell over and was found dead
two days later right like i i've never
seen anybody die from cancer and it's
it's not [ __ ] pretty it's it's it's
not [ __ ] pretty man but no my my
stepdad is currently battling cancer uh
it's terminal and it's it's all kinds of
uh
of awful um oh i gotta warn you i gotta
warn you dear um it's uh you know the
thing is in the movies it's like
no the people will struggle until the
last minute but yeah my whole life
my whole point is like the same thing
with video game design like with me
being a fan of transformers and gi joe
and all that it's all grist for the mill
right and like the thing about
writing is you know these life
experiences for better or for worse
like
they they they fuel you you know you can
you could leverage that to to write
stuff you know and
i think writing is very therapeutic it's
like really the only thoughts of my job
that drive me not so when i have a
million meetings and not enough writing
time that's why i'm like just let me
[ __ ] write something which we'll go
get get that mug that says this uh this
meeting could have been a [ __ ] email
you know genuinely a lot of them
and the the thing is you know like
having worked with programmers as long
as i have i'm very big on brevity like
just cut to the [ __ ] chase like
what's the [ __ ] point yeah right but
the thing is uh i think sometimes you
know like once in a blue moon i'll just
send lauren flowers for shits and
giggles uh because i'm a romantic [ __ ]
um but the thing is is like when you go
to 800 flowers like it gives you the
option for like a pre-typed thing
to say to the person and i'm like
look i know writing's hard but how much
of an uncreative [ __ ] do you
have to be to not like type up like that
people must use it
exactly like to at least come up with a
[ __ ] limerick for your wife talking
about you like you like eating your ass
or something like that anything they
should actually add i will eat your ass
as a
quick option
i did so
i had this shirt that i had made it says
i eat ass in japanese
i think i've seen that
i may have seen that we printed out we
printed up stickers that say that and we
plastered him all around downtown
raleigh and uh like only like three
people noticed it
see i like you know trolling sucks but i
like subtle trolling right um
the meaning of trolling has changed i
love trolling but
like what it used to be is intentionally
annoying someone with something very
minor like an example of trolling is i
had a conversation with somebody once
where i tried to convince them that ash
ketchum from pokemon's last name was
actually ash ketchup this is a very dumb
thing to do but i was like no no it's
ketchup no sir trust me it's ketchup and
then they get frustrated that's trolling
you just make somebody mindly annoyed
with something very meaningless now
yeah these days kill yourself yeah it's
change debate it sucks
for the record i don't understand how
you like deal with everything online
because your engagement is [ __ ] off
the charts i don't see it i think i've
told you that before like i do not
read it
you could you just like like tweet like
a fart and like i'm just like i am girl
i don't read it um and actually for
security reasons i have other people
monitor my tweets uh
both my team and even at sony um so
there are people who do read my tweets
so that i don't have to like for certain
harassment cases which is very nice
yeah yeah i don't doubt you get a lot of
that but back to writing yes
but the thing is okay so when it comes
to reading
like are you a kindle person or you're a
physical book books
dude little stack of books down here we
have this uh this this exactly my like i
i i had this bookshelf installed down
downstairs and it's like it's
overflowing at this point right because
like i used my kindle for a while but
the thing about kindle it started off
like you know like like this size you
know comfortable right
and then it started
turning into like this yeah they got
smaller and smaller my thing is as you
know somebody you know like me lives
online all the time like we stare at
screens all the [ __ ] time exactly
right and then to just sit there and
like there's a local bookstore called
quail ridge books in north hills right
and i had this thing lately where like
also like uh a barnes and noble open
downtown like it's it feels like
physical books are having like a
comeback because there's this saying the
more the world goes digital the more
people will will cling to physical right
yeah that's why this way sentimental
about it
exactly well right you should have had a
huge comeback yeah exactly but just like
walking into a bookstore and the smell
right and i remember reading a story
about
marilyn monroe what she would do is
she'd go into a bookstore and she would
open the book
and read like four or five lines and
she'd know immediately if she wanted to
read it right and the thing is is like
prose is half the battle
right like cormic mccarthy the road his
prose is chef's kiss right um and but
there's sometimes there's been books
that i've started reading and like after
like five pages i'm thinking about like
getting milk at the store and i'm like
totally
i have to reread that look at the [ __ ]
did you ever read uh untamed by glennon
doyle no i mostly read fantasy but i
also just read a lot of non-fiction
just trust me untamed it's a
semi-autobiographical she's a woman she
was
married to a dude and then was wrote a
book about during her her straight
marriage and then went to a book signing
and then this lovely soccer player lady
came to her book signing and she's like
oh my god fell in love with this lady
divorced her husband wow and then like
it ran off into the sunset but her prose
and her it's almost like a self-help
book a self-help book in a lot of ways
it's [ __ ] amazing um but you know
i'll go to these bookstores
and i will wistfully like look at the uh
you know biography section and just you
know fantasize about just seeing that on
the shelves and then i i start thinking
about you know simon and schuster and
thinking about like oh are you gonna
make me do a book tour because um i i'm
social media friends with don winslow
who wrote a
whole bunch of [ __ ] books and he's
he's very prolific on twitter and um he
talks about his book book tour and i'm
like looking at the dates and i'm like
sitting there like am i gonna have to be
in like toledo like what the [ __ ] you
know like it can't be that much worse
than shipping a video game and having to
go to all the international events i
guess except that you have to go to
small towns
again in the word in the words of danny
glover i'm too old for this [ __ ] yeah
it makes sense alana you hit a certain
age we just want a good night's sleep
and a good [ __ ] i think i'm already
there which is the problem
i went out last night
out and i was like uh it's about time to
go to bed
well also the same thing about like you
know going to bars as much as i do like
to vibe is i just want to get a drink i
want to be able to take a piss i want to
have a conversation yeah like i i hate
that
that's where i went last night yeah and
you have to like you're like having it
like hey in people's ears like and [ __ ]
like that i'm just like literally the
person who i i was someone's birthday
and i went out and they were like i
can't hear you just text me tomorrow and
i was like okay i'll text you yeah
no like one of my jams these days is gay
but gay bars oh yeah they've always been
fun oh like i never see like i never see
[ __ ] fights
you know like if i get hit on it's
flattering yeah you know and then like
if my wife gets it on she's flattered
it's not gonna be some dude like how you
doing you know like it's it's the
funniest thing when dudes try and roll
on her it's like dude there's nothing
you're going to be able to say to like
convince her of anything try their best
oh they will like but anyway she's a
baby it's going to happen
and you know she's she's my she's my
forever person but yeah but the thing is
um she's been you know
so supportive of the book yeah um it's
dedicated to her um and uh you know it's
it's so weird because people are gonna
pick it up you know it was pitched to
simon schuster
as
the kitchen confidential for video games
you know anthony bourdain rest in peace
still miss him to this [ __ ] day yeah
um and uh you know it is really like
seeing inside how the sausage is made
without violating ndas and things like
that
but again very very very personal and uh
very excited to read it november 1st so
uh when's your when's your memoir coming
out
maybe give me a few more years before i
start on that one well so the thing the
thing i'm sure you're learning about
video game writing is that
you can have a main character that has
like a flamethrower right and then like
like he has to get cut from the game
because like the flamethrower was like
hurting the frame rate too much and then
you have to go all the way back through
all those threads and like rewrite and
re-fucking edit everything right and
like
i'm good friends with this that's been a
very big part of my job rewrites are a
huge thing
yep didn't expect that to the extent
that it is well it's a good thing you
already have the platinum here because
it'll turn your hair grey god it'll be
cheaper
i've seen so many like game developers
like go into the business in like within
three it's kind of like obama when he
went into office
and like you know like
two years later he goes from like having
the dark hair just being like totally
like you know white hair but the thing
is is um
i'm good friends with tom bissell um he
wrote uh gears 4
gears 5. um he wrote the disaster artist
which is the book about the movie the
rome which wound up being turned into
that movie with james franco and whatnot
produced by seth rogen and uh he
basically publicly said that like he
wound up like in the hospital with heart
palpitations from all the rewrites he
had to do on gears yep right and he also
kind of did it solo like yeah he almost
did all about himself um
yeah he he did wind up in the hospital
that's terrifying but the the thing is
just like he in his book the whole point
is he wound up comparing his cocaine
addiction to the way video games can be
addictive and like his addiction to
grand theft auto right which is a really
interesting kind of you know venn
diagram overlap but um you know a lot of
respect for uh from him he actually has
a blurb in the back here so nice that's
it
yeah i wanted to ask before we move on
from the book you finished it what what
do you feel like is like the biggest
thing you learned like about writing for
for actually finishing it like what was
the thing when maybe when you started
that you wish you could tell yourself
it's a lot like shipping a game
no way you know it really is you know
there's iteration iteration iteration
um and then you know like what happens
also and you're gonna find when you ship
your game i don't know is this your
first game that you're you're gonna be
shipping
uh technically no but it would be the
one that i've been the most involved in
i've been at the studio for two years so
okay well there's you know the the it's
not a one to one because i hate to
compare it to to like women in pregnancy
especially considering the current
climate what's going on um
there's this thing when you ship a game
now it's live products and it's like go
go but back in the day you'd ship a game
and be done maybe a little dlc right now
it's called seasons
um and it was that thing where um
you'd get postpartum depression
yeah you know you would be like okay i
did it
no no what yeah yeah exactly jinx
i feel like i've had that happen like e3
every year at ign it was like you just
you crunched that whole week or even the
two months leading up to it you're
crunching and then that week is like two
hours sleep a night and it's it's nuts
or what was back in the day well as you
know
like
now what yeah well at these conventions
you're also burning the candle at both
ends right oh yeah you know you work
work work all day long go out and you
know hang out with friends you know oh i
haven't seen you in a while but i have a
few drinks blah blah blah you know get a
little bit of sleep and then you get
home and you sit in the sofa and like
you get that almost like tinnitus of
silence they're like
and you're like
i would intentionally fall asleep on the
couch at e3 while working for aegean
with the window open so that the sun
would wake me at 8am just to make sure i
got up because that's how how
sleep-deprived i was i was like setting
myself up to make sure that i woke up
otherwise i'd miss a [ __ ] 8 a.m
interview with some
developer on the show floor he's a great
a great part of my convention life and
and lauren as well was red bull and
claritin d yeah clarendon d is the it's
the ultimate hangover cure
and i'm surprised considering the fact
that heart disease runs in my family i
didn't have a [ __ ] heart attack back
in those days because
you again like i said you're burning the
candle [ __ ] both ends yeah when i
would throw that yacht party it was like
the culmination of like the highlight of
my year and you know when i would go
there in the words of justin royland i
would get as you
probably recall get quite swifty
um and so yeah yeah gotta get swifty
take off your pants take a [ __ ] on the
floor
um but yeah i'm bummed it's not gonna
happen this year but you know justin's
uh justin's doing well um we still stay
in touch i somehow wanna transitioning
from writing yes what did you learn or
like give me a tip about finishing a
book
it's
[ __ ] hard man i don't doubt that you
know like like it's it's one thing to
write fiction right you know like i'm
working on a comic book right now right
i've been somewhat public about it right
the thing is you know working with alex
decampi
um she wrote uh maddie for duncan jones
who did uh source code moon and world
war warcraft um we're twitter buddies
too i'm like i'm twitter buddies with
david bowie's son okay that's crazy
um oh he's
fantastic and so um what she does is
like i give her like my general outline
of like where i want the story to go
right you know and like my sloppy cliff
you know typing like cloudy with a
chance of meatballs hands right that's
the best way to do it in my opinion like
my biggest tip for people who want to
finish writing things
sought it like a kid's book if you want
to finish something don't start it very
intricate and detailed in every
paragraph or you'll just end up
rewriting and editing the same
paragraphs over and over write it like a
kid's book and then this happened and
this happened and then this happened
well michael actually finish it well
there's a pixar master class on that
right like once upon a time there was so
and so and things were going fine until
one day and then this that and the other
and you know i'm friends with the
students you should also always focus on
therefore rather than and so this
happened therefore this happened
therefore this happened rather than and
and it's a very useful thing to remind
yourself when writing so i'm good
friends with the stu beattie of
philawasi uh he's a prolific
screenwriter director um and he was
gonna you know write the he wrote a
draft of the gears movie and he taught
me one time that like in his opinion a
good a good movie a good a good like
fiction
novel is something where characters at
the start of the book or the movie like
at the end of the movie do something you
wouldn't have expected at the start yeah
right like you know and it goes back to
star wars you know which is also there's
also a book i can't remember the name of
it right now but it basically talks
about like people love things that are
familiar yet twisted a little bit right
and star wars is basically the japanese
uh movie uh hidden fortress but
retold by way of sci-fi like the the
mandalorian
is uh kind of there's a western about uh
a dude and a child that he's escorting
and so if you you think about the
mandalorian it's essentially it's a it's
a western right and so star wars you
know luke is you know he's on the
moisture farm he's just this like you
know little whiny farm boy right and
then eventually he winds up like you
know wrecking the empire like becoming
this you know badass with the force
right and so you know what i remember
like you know when i was a kid when i
saw a return to the jedi and he shows up
wearing all black it's just total badass
job of the hutt's palace i was just like
this is [ __ ] great you know like
that's it yeah that's the hero
well that's exactly this is there's an
anecdote in my book about that where i
was
at a bar in milan on a gears press tour
and i was talking to this gentleman
about narrative and things like that and
for those of you who don't know it's uh
joseph campbell wrote this book called
the hero's journey which is required uh
reading if you want to be a writer and
and he basically like you know just kind
of outlines you know that and so in the
book i actually have my own hero's
journey right uh it goes back to the
iliad and the odyssey you know the homer
homer's epic and epics and whatnot so uh
you know writing is one of those things
uh you know like
same thing with game design you know
like when i have a game id i just i will
type out just
a page and it just it'll be sloppy it'll
have typos but it's kind of like mold
and clay you know and it's gonna be all
nasty and then you just start
like kind of editing it and moving it
but the the key is
it's like sculpting right like you don't
want to chip away at it too much you
know there's the classic saying
actually i'm going to go back to mad max
fury road
brilliant film
the the best part about it is the doof
guy with the with the [ __ ] guitar so
like
and like a lot of practical
exactly but so many people are like i
like the movie except for the guy with
the guitar i'm like [ __ ] people didn't
like that guy
yes i'm like that was the [ __ ] best
part right and it's the same
focus groups what they could do is
there's this uh cartoon i saw years ago
where they said you know like you have
something unique shape and they're like
and somebody comes in and edits it to
make it like into just a perfect
rectangle so it fits in with all the
other rectangles
removing everything that makes it unique
right and so the thing is if you're if
you're going to write a memoir or if you
can write fiction like find your voice
and make it your own you know and and
iterate it reiterate and get a good
editor and get a good publisher if you
can
well very good
that's my ted talk it's very good ted
talk also good for indie devs like both
of those things it's like absolutely
my addiction these days is learning like
businesses you know i know how video
games work um i'm learning how the
restaurant business works
we're fortunate enough to own the real
estate so
learning more about real estate um
learning how broadway works uh learning
how the comic industry works uh learning
how the publishing world and it works
and whatnot and just uh there's so much
overlap but they're so different so it's
just been a really really really
fascinating hero's journey that's a
great position to be in i hope i am
where you are when i'm your age that's
like that sounds awesome you're just
choosing to dabble in things that you
find interesting and learning a bunch
about them and investing in projects
that you like that's that's doug real
quick before we go do you get recognized
often
relatively
yeah so like like once a week or so or i
would say like
once every time i go out
yep well that's well you're more
obviously again your engagement's way
more than mine i don't go out that much
though so
why do you ask
i know the thing is i i tweeted that i
got recognized the other night by a few
fans and uh it was at my beer garden and
uh they're like you know i tweeted like
you know
they wanted to like buy me a drink and
i'm like no i'm buying you a drink you
helped pay for my [ __ ] house
and it [ __ ] like it blew up and uh
that's the thing is like you know like
my the kind of fame that i have
which is you know somewhat limited
it's the best kind of game because yeah
it's like only once every week or two
right
it's not like i ca i can't go to the
supermarket or anything like that you
know you're in an interesting position
where a lot of people might know your
name rather than know your face as well
there might be people who know your name
and know what you've done but actually
not be able to recognize you on the
street which is kind of awesome well now
i have the beard of stealth too it's
true hides everything no one can tell
who you are now one of my uh girlfriends
said to me one time that uh beards are
makeup for men it's true
if men are out here complaining about
contour then women should be allowed to
complain about beards
exactly exactly uh so before i let you
go i did want to ask some hard hitting
video game questions what do you think
is um the best game ever written in
terms of writing
i'd say bioshock
yeah i can't i can't argue with that
i think ken levine's a [ __ ] genius
and yeah like
to pull that
m night shyamalan kind of twist
you know with would you kindly like the
fact that it ties into gameplay is what
gets me
exactly it's about play it's about
player agency are you playing the game
or is it playing you yeah right and
that's [ __ ] brilliant and for the
record the greatest game of all time
still remains tetris
i think it's portal
yeah portal's pretty [ __ ] genius what
a one and two i think are the best games
ever made i think it's hard to argue
against putting portal on top of a list
tetris as well though like and the fact
that tetris still holds up so well my
favorite game is doom 1993 and even that
is kind of similar where it's like
something that i play it today and i'll
still fully understand everything it
still [ __ ] holds up like
that game design hasn't aged the first
half of my career i i hated john romero
and all that i wanted to like you know
take him down and all that stuff and
we're friends we're friends now years
later um you know we're like croatia
like you know hanging out with him and
brenda um but the thing is is like
doom broke the mold you know like that
they were you know there's a reason why
kushner wrote the book masters of doom
right they were the [ __ ] beatles then
tried to turn into a tv show
yeah we were talking about it but uh
covet apparently [ __ ] that so
hopefully hopefully it still happens
because
silicon valley can be a big show um did
you watch silicon valley yeah i loved it
my catchphrase from russ henneman when i
see somebody who's confident i'm like
this guy [ __ ] yeah it's a common one
it's non-stop nonstop so yeah um
the next question is going to be where
would you like to see video game writing
go is there any way that you feel like
uh there's a direction that you strongly
want video game narrative to head in
something you want to see more of i
always tell developers when possible to
make it personal
like if you look at the gears trilogy
the first three
you know it was about the fact that rod
ferguson lee perry and i we lost our
fathers at an early age right and so you
know it's all about marcus phoenix and
his dad adam and how eventually you know
marcus thought he saw his father die you
know at the beginning and then at the
end his father you know
activated his device but experimented on
himself with it and marcus
saw his dad turn to ashes in front of
him a lot like a lot like what happened
in avengers anyway you did it first
yeah exactly simpsons did it
but just that's the thing is you know
make it personal and and
for developers i hope they continue to
try to try to find that balance between
player agency
and telling the story you know there's
so many ways in a video game to tell the
story from passive narrative of you know
scrapbooking picking up a post-it uh you
know reading logs or something like that
you know like system shock to the ghosts
are appearing in front of you
and you're like oh what happened here
you know you're kind of deciphering the
story yourself and then also having
cutscenes so i think continuing to find
that balance is going to be tricky
especially
in the world we are in with seasons and
living products and things like that
right sure so it's uh it's it's evolving
it's ever evolving and uh just hoping
it'll put more uh writers in the
hospital like tom bissell
oh boy i don't doubt that that's
happening more frequently than we
realize
keep an eye on the blood pressure alana
yeah hey i'm good i feel like i'm
treated super well thankfully like that
the studio is very very very good um
very compassionate like i asked if i
could go home to australia and they were
like yeah no worries i was working at
3am but i was allowed to for like a
month it was it was awesome it was so
nice that's that's that's that's called
good management which is often rare in
the video game industry my manager is
[ __ ] fantastic because sometimes i'll
be like hey i have a doctor's
appointment uh i have to do this work
can i do this at this time he was like
yeah just as long as you get the work
done just take your [ __ ] doctor's
appointment for it i've had managers
before who are like you can only take a
doctor's appointment between these hours
and you must schedule it this far in
advance and like it's oh jesus christ
yeah it's santa monica studio more than
anywhere else i've ever worked i get
treated like a human which is
wonderful
there's a reason
they keep they keep cranking up
fantastic games i think so too yeah um
the last question i wanted to ask before
i let you go is what's something that
you see in video game writing or
narrative design that you don't like
what would be your least favorite i
don't know trope recurring thing
something about video game writing that
you you aren't a fan of and why
i got to think about this for a second
um
i don't like like shock writing you know
i think everything
it kind of goes back to stand-up comedy
which i'm a huge fan of as well
like you can joke about anything
as long as you frame it within the right
context i believe sure um but that's the
thing again like it's just you know
don't just write for shock value you
know like write and have a purpose have
a theme and like you know there's a
reason they call some writers hacks
you know and and again video game
writing is hard right but you know try
and have a point and like
you know i do think it's a lot easier if
you ground things in personal experience
where you can well you'll have an easier
time writing exactly always make it
personal the thing i you know a quick
personal anecdote is that you know going
back to like you know when gears was you
know
one two and three you know it was out
the comments were all like this this is
a stupid bro game blah blah blah i
[ __ ] love gears gears 2 made me cry
well that's the thing thank you um once
in a while i'll go to youtube and i'll
look up some of those like you know
seminal cut scenes and i'll read the
comments and like
we we kind of [ __ ] up an entire
generation in a good way i like even
back when i was playing those games i
don't know i was 13 or some [ __ ]
i found that offensive like people would
be like years as a bro shooter and i'd
be like have you played it sure they
look like human tree trunks but i like i
found two especially all the stuff with
tai even
super emotional
yeah i mean you know like that's the
other thing is you know like make sure
your stuff has heart you know like like
almost every pixar movie i see makes me
cry
you know like like look at the first
the first uh sequence and up
like they they put you on this express
train it's so good to tears within like
what the span of like four minutes
right without any [ __ ] dialogue right
like that is a master class in writing
and directing uh cinematography and
everything and uh you know just make
people feel stuff you know and and don't
be offense or just to be offensive um
any closing thoughts cliff is there
anything else that you would like to
share with the world
i will always love video games i will
always love the industry
but
i'm still going to consult i'm still
going to work in other things the thing
is right now what i'm doing is i'm just
working on multiple ips cool and you
know spending my own dime on them and
we'll see where it goes you know if it
becomes a video game [ __ ] awesome if
it becomes a netflix series cool it
becomes a movie that's cool too but i'm
lucky enough to have the freedom to
pursue different things that i want to
now that i'm largely removed from the
industry but i like really
truly appreciate everybody who supported
me throughout the years i'm glad your
passion hasn't died video games are
awesome i just like my sleep at a good
[ __ ] i get it
uh where can people find you
um on twitter i'm at the real cliffy b
um that's the only one you really need i
plug my instagram on there sometimes but
i'm not a butt model so there's no point
let's be honest
instagram is for butts
yeah i probably don't follow enough butt
related accounts i follow a lot of art
there's an instagram account called butt
snorkeller
wow
and they just they they aggregate all
like the lovely butt models of instagram
and i'll be sitting there at a bar with
my wife and i'm like and there's a class
that's a pretty good book i mostly
follow dogs and artists i'm pretty sure
and personal friends i need more butts i
think you've done that thing with like
where once in a while like you you
you'll be in a bad mood you're just like
you'd be like just just send me
pictures of your [ __ ] dogs you know
like yeah
yeah good love a good dog bait real
quick a quick final note like you know i
don't know if you've seen the tweet
about the the dog thing that i posted
right um kind of don bluth style like a
kind of uh huskies kind of looking over
this domed city and whatnot right
is that the inspiration for that ip
came from
right behind me
is my shrine to my australian shepherd
that i had for 13 years he was there
through my first marriages uh crumbling
he was there through
through gears games um i had to put him
down which was one of the hardest days
of my life and then after the year of
spontaneous crying stopped uh lauren
lauren found this pomsky which is mostly
husky i think i've seen walking paws in
the background
yeah yeah yeah um and so basically um
the thing is
i'm friends with d d from game of
thrones and i was lucky enough to go up
to the final season premiere in new york
and then wound up partying with the cast
in their suite until four in the morning
then we went up on the way back scooping
up this pomsky and i told myself i have
a belief that feelings are like
tributaries roots you know rivers you
can redirect them in certain ways and i
told them
my brain i'm like
in my heart i'm like let's just take
every ounce of sadness i have from
losing teddy and pour it into love for
lady yeah and so then lady she's such a
weird goofy she's mostly husky uh goofy
beautiful little creature and every time
i take her out to go potty you know i
give her a little kiss
and uh you know i tell her how much i
love her and um she's basically been my
inspiration for uh this uh this ip that
i'm working on and so that goes back to
you know my final note is make it
personal
very good closing thought make it
personal everybody thank you for joining
me cliff november 1st get the book
november 1st
and uh thanks for watching everybody
i'll see you next time always good
seeing you
[Music]
you